hey guys I'm markiplier I know how much
you love top tens so here's a list of
the top 10 things I do when I'm not
making Let's Plays enjoy number 10
number nine so thank you guys so much
for watching and as always is that the
wasp I will see you that was a wasp Baba
he died number eight
[Music]
number seven you can do this everyone on
the internet loves you're a big star
like 80% of the people are but that's
still see and it seems a passing grade
Tuesday code number six I could have
been an engineer number five number four
mark I don't think this is such a good
idea
oh shut up Jacques it's number three
markiplier number two
[Music]
well good so much much and number one
hey guys I just wanted to say honestly
and truly thank you guys so much for
supporting me I do have a lot of fun
doing YouTube for a living and I do
enjoy very much I really don't regret a
single thing especially not going to
engineering school and finishing that up
I really do love the fact that I get to
entertain you guys every single day so
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always and I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]